So now that we have 3 pieces of information,
let's put these pieces together.
So the first two that we will put together
is the statement here on the second line
and this one here on the third line.
So we know that the length of the tour computed by the algorithm
is exactly two times the weight of the minimum spanning tree.
Now we will use the piece of information that we will have up here,
so let's make a little bit more space down here.
We know that the length of the shortest tour is larger than
the weight of the minimum spanning tree,
so we can put this part down here.
Now isn't that beautiful.
At least I think so.
So the length of the shortest tour must lie somewhere
in between the weight of the minimum spanning tree
and the solution that you have just computed,
which is twice the weight of the spanning tree.
And this means that the algorithm I specified here is actually
a constant factor approximation algorithm for shortest tour.
Oh, I forgot to write the factor here.
Well, of course I did that deliberately
because this is going to be your final quiz
for this algorithm.
Please tell me what is the approximation factor,
using this information we've just figured out,
that this algorithm has for shortest tour?